[Music]
all right let's go out to Atlanta
Georgia and talk to the Great and
Powerful Laura what's up Laura hello
hello and I'm too old to go to a GRE you
you listen listen you are not at the
last Turn Style Show I went to um I went
with how old 55 I will be 50 by the time
we go see Creed so is too old uh he's
three years older than me so 3 he did
break a rib at that show it got pretty
wild but no man you can go anything you
want
to no I'm more like uh lonel
Richie Barry Manalo kind you know that's
my age group Barry Manalo and Neil
Diamond was the first concert I ever
went to my parents took me I was that's
a great one I was a new I was an infant
um yeah it's lodged in there the first
show I remember was the oid boys in
Chicago man that was a time ago all
right so what's up how can I help well I
hope that you can help me untangle some
of the mess that I'm in um first of all
my ex-husband we've been divorced three
years um just won't leave me alone
constantly sends me texts about I miss
you um you know I can't be without you
you know texts phone calls emails
whatever now the background is we've
been together since we were seniors in
high school if we had stayed together
last week would have been our 40th
anniversary but I married him and
divorced him twice because he's a
cheater oh so you won't you won't cut
him
off you need him well the problem is I'm
an only
child um my father is 94 years old and
has caregivers and is at his house and
you need him Like Oxygen cuz you're
scared to death of being
alone I don't know that I'm scared of
being alone he's scared of being alone
I'm not then why won't you block him and
cut him off and never talk to him again
ever he's he's destroyed your life
multiple times well this is true this is
true but I have three children that are
married one uh one of them you're
deflecting why won't you cut him why
won't you cut him off forever and say
you've destroyed my life multiple times
by cheating and cheating and cheating
you're not weaseling your way back in
again explain to him that we will never
be together again ever yeah but you've
told them that two other
times oh this is
true and probably I may be wrong may be
wrong but in between your divorces y'all
probably had some flings
too you mean with each other or yeah
with each other yeah
yeah yeah so he's just business as
usual yeah that's right he just thinks
he's gonna come right back in anymore he
has every time of course he has you're
exactly right so when when somebody
tells me like hey somebody won't quit
contacting me my first question is well
are you talking to them and they go well
yes are you like responding back yes are
you taking care of them well I mean kind
of yes are you making plans I mean sort
of yes or it's absolutely not it's
harassment and called the police but I'm
guessing you're more of the of the
former yeah I am because I'm somebody
that always wants everybody to be happy
I've learned that right and um with my
dad he wanted to you know once this all
happened a couple years ago he said you
know I don't have any family left but
I'm very close to your dad and I'd love
to be able to go see your dad you know
one day a week so he takes some dinner
on
Sundays now you know I asked my dad if
that was okay at first my dad was like
you know you know and then he said well
okay so it got to be where he's wiggled
his way back in and he has not yeah he
hasn't he has created a relationship
with or continued a relationship with
your dad if I was your dad okay I'd have
my feelings hurt in a significant way I
mean I'm sorry if I was you and my dad
was doing that was continuing to meet
with my ex-wife who had blown my life up
and destroyed my kids lives twice um I
would be hurt by that but my dad d a
grown man can make his own choices I
hate well my dad has dementia so you
know it's kind like there you go he
hasn't we weasel his way back in unless
he starts messing around with the will
and things like that that's weaseling
back in but you are allowing him into
your
life okay I just don't know why you're
doing that unless you just say hey I
love him he's cheated on me twice we've
been divorced twice but I don't want to
be alone and I do love him and he's hurt
me bad but here we are and you make
peace with
that
okay where where is your like where's
your like digestive issues come from
like where does that like what's what's
the what's the
hangup well probably it's because we
have I have three grown children one of
them has grand um grandchildren that uh
were were in contact with him you know
before all this happened they did stuff
together my other children have had
babies since our divorce and they he has
never met those babies because my
children saw him cheating so you know
that's a whole another different story
they were the ones that saw him the last
time first but you're but you're you're
they're grown adults they get to do that
yeah and I guess it just hurts me
because I think about he doesn't get to
see them it you know I I guess I do care
about him I don't love him care about it
it's because of choices he
made that's right I think you do care
about him and I think you'd probably be
bananas if you didn't have a little bit
of like love in there somewhere I think
the bigger picture is how old are
you 65 65 I think you had a really
really crystal clear picture of what
your life was going to look like at 65
and that guy blew it up now this is
absolutely true and he admits it yeah
you know I'm sorry I did all that well
too bad except not too bad because you
keep going back to him y'all keep y'all
keep going out well I'm not going out
with him yes you I mean I don't do so no
I don't I don't do anything no I do not
see him okay I talk to him on the phone
I do not see him how does it how I
getting ready to go on a trip he wanted
to come over here and tell me goodbye I
said what are you talking about and I
just blew up because he's follow he's
just following the tracks yall have
followed before okay which is y'all got
divorced he cheated on you y'all got
divorced you said I'm I'm
uh I'm not going to have this in my
house I'm not going to be married to
someone who treats me like this and who
cheats on me and my and the kids and
then it started with well hey we have to
talk because of the kids and then it
started a text message and it started in
a phone call then hey let's just go grab
coffee and then you end up married again
no i't doing that I know that okay so
what's the benefit of the in
between I don't think there's any
benefit then why don't you block him and
cut him off and say I'm never talking to
you again I'm moving on with my life
okay I'm I'm just I'm not saying you
have to do that I'm just proposing that
why why hav't you done that I just well
okay here's the deal uh he has no
friends that's his problem that's a
choice he's made go what else no money
that's a choice a choice he's made
that's a choice he's made I I understand
that um he has health problems and went
to the hospital and you know they said
we don't you know we've got to figure
out what this is you may be having
congestive heart failure what he's got a
heart trouble he's got five stents in
his heart so I am the only
one that can help him there's nobody
else that can help my the child that
talks to him doesn't live
here
so you know what do you say I'm sorry
you're sick and you may die I I'll see
you later I mean I I can't in my heart I
can't do that then you have to make
peace with taking his phone calls and
his text messages
and you have to make peace that maybe
you're not his wife maybe you all don't
have romantic interests but now you're
his mother well that's true I am his
mother you're his
mom so make peace with
that okay he chose on multiple occasions
to not be in relationship with
you he chose to not be in relationship
with his kids by his actions
correct and and you have chosen to not
let go of this fantasy that you've held
on to for almost 40
years and I'm not telling you you have
to let it go but here's what I want I
want you to make peace with it okay if
you're gonna take care of this dead beat
and you're GNA take care of him and pay
his bills and make sure he's got chicken
noodle
soup then make peace with that but
that's not what I want to do and if you
want him out of your
life like you called and said he won't
quit calling me well of course not
you're his
mom yeah so if you're not going to take
care of him then cut him off and say I'm
I'm I can't do this this isn't my
responsibility to take care of you call
the Social Security office and I mean I
wish you the
best but you can't heal him you can't
make him be a person of character he's
not going to be you can't make your kids
your kids seem to have more intestinal
fortitude than you do
yes I
do so I just make peace with
it okay do you see an do you see an
alternative you know what I mean yeah
there isn't I mean yes I I agree I
understand no I don't want to be his mom
though I don't want the rest of my wife
being his mom but you've already decided
that's the case you said like I can't
let him just you know pay his own bills
I need I need to get some you need to
get some
backbone my problem all along well
that's been my problem all along yeah I
remarried him why did I do that I should
have never done that well it's in
hindsight but you were trying to keep
that fantasy
together gotcha and fantasies are
powerful man hope is a powerful thing
it's
incredible
yeah so I'm I'm fascinated what are you
going to
do
well I don't know I got to think about
it I got to figure out what what I
can let me let me say it this way where
does this end and what I mean by that is
this if he has five stance and he's
entering into congestive heart failure
he doesn't have a long
time and so are you going to write it
out for a couple years with him as he
passes and make sure he doesn't die
alone or or you going to use your
retirement that you had to save on your
own as a single mom cuz he left you a
few times to go run around on you are
you going to save that money and
whatever inheritance your 94 year old
father leaves
you to take care of him for the next 15
years and all of his surgeries and all
of his Healthcare and his skilled
nursing and all
that
no that's the question not and so I
think the fair thing to do is to have
that conversation because in his mind
you've always taken care of him for 40
years more than half his life yes and so
it's fair to say hey this this train is
over I can't in good conscience take
money that go to my grandkids and
support a guy who left me
twice or that's absolutely right or um
I'm GNA take care of this and this and
this and then that's it what am I
supposed to do I don't know I don't know
MH you should call the Social Security
office and see where you're
at
yeah
yeah see what I'm see what I'm
saying
exactly and I don't mean to be cruel to
him but man he's used you for a long
long long time oh yes he has yes he
has yes and your kids your kids could
see it that they're worth more than
being
used and I guess my hope for you Laura
is
that even after all this time you're
able to grieve what have been your 40th
anniversary how amazing would that have
been and your kids would have been there
and the grandkids would have been there
that's how it was supposed to
be and it's
not and every single person listening to
this call myself self-included has a
picture of the way things were supposed
to be and they're not and the quicker we
can sit in what is choose reality we can
sit in that and just exhale and weep
and then our bodies learn that we're in
the driver seat of our own life and we
can then go about making and painting a
new picture all right what's the time
left I'm
65 statistically I've got 10 to 15 years
but potentially I've got 20 years left
my dad's 94 maybe I can do 95 20 or 30
years I'm sorry what do I want to do
with the last
30 I his mom cool you can do that I'm
not going to get mad at you for it you
get your life you get to choose I'm
gonna move in buy my grandkids and just
R like be the greatest grandma of all
time you get to pick you get to pick you
get to
pick I do think it's fair to have a hard
conversation whatever that's going to
look like I'm going to continue to take
care of you even though you've hurt me
but here's my boundaries because I'm
your mom now or hey this train ends
where I'm done done I'm done this money
is going to take care of me for the rest
of my life and for these
babies